robots will create winter syndrome to
people set that meeting crying thank me
when I have a job and my generation in
this town is there's no future for us
here people who will be most affected
are not the people with power but you
have a segment of America that's so
angry it's so left behind it's so
ignorant that you know this week they're
feeding all of this hatred in this anger
[Music]
this is a tale of two Americas the one
that collapsed and the one that's about
to the manufacturing decline caused the
hollowing out of the American heartland
but the big question now is what cities
will automation destroy many of the
cities expected to be hit the hardest
have the feel of a boomtown but that
will change as automated vehicles
service robotics and artificial
intelligence displace jobs by the
millions
Las Vegas is the very place where we
expect the highest amount of jobs and
the rest to being automated way by
robots and drones and artificial
intelligence that's Johannes ammonius a
professor of Business who has been
studying where automation is going to
hit the hardest some of those jobs are
high-paying like loan officers and
paralegals while others are classic
blue-collar professions like security
guards and drivers Johannes took those
studies and looked at which American
cities could be most affected by
automation
he found that 65% of the jobs in Las
Vegas could technically be automated in
the coming decade Hannes was in town to
present his findings at an Economic
Forum he didn't have good news it's a
hard message to deliver because today
Vegas is doing relatively well you know
that's I'm actually expecting that this
will happen no matter what it's hard to
predict where it's going to happen
[Music]
part of the reason Vegas is prone to
automation is the high number of service
jobs and though few expect all jobs to
be replaced a few robots are already
working at this point the robot is more
of a gimmick than a replacement of a
worker but it's a glimpse of what's
coming oh my name is Jeremy Begbie I'm a
technician here for the robots I uh
monitor them whenever I'm here make sure
they're running properly many in the
tech world argue that advancements will
create more jobs and Jeremy serves as
one of those examples at least as far as
our bar goes there's not really that
threat of automation they're nowhere
near being as good as an actual
bartender and I think that when they
established this place the idea was hey
look at this look at this robot bar
that's pretty cool look at the robots
making you drink it's kind of cute look
at them they shake it that's cool no
one's gonna want to talk to a robot
until they have a personality of course
then we'll see I actually ordered
cosmopolitan because I knew it was gonna
have like some shaking and stuff like
that to go ahead and see some of the
cool stuff and what do you think um it
was a strong automation is already
making steady gains in Las Vegas Nevada
''s Casino employment peaked in 2001 at
fifty nine thousand nine hundred and
eight by 2016 it had dropped to less
than 41,000 it's not just the strip jobs
on the outskirts of the city are at risk
in call centers loan offices and
restaurants in ten years Las Vegas could
look like America's Rust Belt does today
now look at them and say hey do you know
that your job specifically has a
probability of more than 90% of being
gone a couple of years down the road the
manufacturing collapse hit hundreds of
towns with endless rounds of layoffs and
factory closures that gutted the middle
class in the American heartland the
numbers of manufacturing jobs that are
lost especially in the Rust Belt
we're losing companies it's it's
unbelievable
one after another just one after another
we've been through technological change
before just not at this pace the first
Industrial Revolution started in the
late 1700s with the mechanical loom
while the second threw out things like
mass production assembly lines and
electricity
the third was defined by computers in
the beginning of automation in
manufacturing job displacement in this
fourth Industrial Revolution is already
underway as automated vehicles drones
robots and artificial intelligence are
all coming online my name is Brenda
Barrow and I worked a uniting technology
carrier for 25 years they replaced a
human with a robot naturally there was a
lot of kinks there first and the process
of learning how to run it properly but I
got used to it Brenda's Factory became a
major political symbol in 2016 when
president-elect Trump came to the
factory and promised to save jobs but
deep down a lot of people knew he wasn't
going to save
Trump met with the CEO of carrier and
announced that they had reached an
agreement because they're not leaving
this country they're not going to leave
this country and the workers are gonna
keep their jobs the former leader of the
local Steel Workers Union Chuck Jones
literally did not believe what he was
hearing I'm sitting vacant the lyin son
of a bitch Trump attacked Chuck on
Twitter but Trump exaggerated the number
of jobs staying in Minneapolis after the
announcement see NBC's Jim Cramer
interviewed carriers CEO we're gonna
make up 16 million dollar investment in
that Factory in Indianapolis to automate
to drive the cost down so that we can
continue to be competitive that
ultimately means is there will be fewer
jobs Automation is well underway and its
effects are so severe that some
economists are already calling it the
great displacement 85 percent of the
manufacturing jobs lost during the first
decade of the century were due to
technological change not to
international trade the effects seen in
manufacturing are set to spread to other
industries twenty-five people were
employed for every 1 million dollars of
manufacturing in the 1980s today just
five workers are needed for the same
output Galesburg Illinois became the
political poster child for the
manufacturing collapse after a Maytag
refrigerator plant moved to Mexico in
2004 the town was a vibrant symbol of
American success for decades
I'm Richard Lindstrom where a 92 year
old business started by my grandfather
Lindstrom's is the store that sold those
Maytag refrigerators on Main Street we
struggled as a downtown to try to keep
keep those customers still coming here
our population probably has shrunk maybe
10 to 15 percent Oh from its high it's
high point in the in the mid 60s now
Galesburg is representative of America's
Main Street that still hasn't fully
bounced back more than a decade after
big manufacturing left a technology and
global competition they're not going
away
those old days aren't coming back as a
refrigerator rent bumped by these people
who were working on it they signed their
names so it's your name on here
somewhere
well I'm here there we go Mike Patrick I
wanted to see what the empty factories
of the Rust Belt could tell me about
what's coming for the towns that empty
from automation so what was it like when
the plant closed well it's like such a
helpless feeling a former Union man in
Galesburg Mike Patrick told me that
automation has been a concern for
decades and that the Maytag plant
steadily required fewer workers as a
result when they shut down we had in the
plant we had around 1600 people running
the same production we would have been
had 4,000 after plant closures young
workers were often able to find new
occupations while older workers retired
or struggled to get by there was one job
where the refrigerators rolled by and I
just put a stick the energy kind sticker
that goes on there and just put it on it
I was like you're gonna do this for 20
more years or you gonna do something
else so worked just down Main Street
Walt McAllister opened a sandwich shop
in the year that Maytag closed his son
Stephen is a local college student who
runs a news website as it became more
and more real I think the town got a
little desperate trying to find anything
to replace the black the loss of jobs
manufacturing and my generation in this
town is there's no future for us here
and it doesn't seem like the city really
cares because they don't really want to
make one or what won't even listen to
what we believe will make a town that we
would want to stay in yeah how's that
make you feel
oh it's heartbreaking it's heartbreaking
there's a myth that the loss of
manufacturing was due entirely to
international trade and numerous
politicians have capitalized on anger
against foreign governments and workers
we're going to pursue new trade deals
that create higher wages and more
opportunities for American workers
bringing back those magnificent words
made in the USA the reality is that
automation has also been a major factor
manufacturing productivity is no longer
directly tied to employment output is
actually at an all-time high
only employment didn't follow around
2000 it fell off a cliff
that's automation and those jobs won't
ever come back some experts say
automation has contributed to a decline
in the US labor force now at 62 point
seven percent of the total population so
what would you say to towns that are
looking out five years or looking out
ten years at this people that's coming
what needs to happen don't make the
mistake that but Galesburg made 14 years
ago don't act like it's not coming it's
coming what do you want your town to be
like in ten years
without those jobs those jobs aren't
going to exist back in Indianapolis
Kathleen works at the same plant that
Brenda did in a big way more poor people
than you know be rich
[Music]
Cathleen doesn't expect her job at
carrier to last much longer and she's
gotten involved in union work she's
currently one of the top five officers
in the local right now running Union
office at work and so you don't know
when our job will eventually play out
but pretty soon pretty sure it's going
to get so the unknown yeah have you
heard people that have found similar
level jobs and definitely no jobs with
the same amount of pay a lot of people
just you know mentally just like in
shock about you know what their next
move is gonna be oh you always want to
remain optimistic on anything and with
the the situation as it is there's not a
lot of good paying jobs these people are
gonna be able to coach him and you know
the most part lot of people's lives are
ruined
so the thing that keeps me up at night
is the fact that the people who will be
most affected are kind of in the worst
position to do something about it jest
Shen is an expert on the potential
effects of automation we drove around
Las Vegas and just pointed out
neighborhoods that her research suggests
are at the highest risk and we find that
Hispanics have a 25% higher chance of
having their job automated than whites
and african-americans have a 13% higher
chance than whites of job automation the
first fully automated shuttle launched
in Vegas last year and it's not just
driving a diverse range of jobs could
disappear throughout the city
we gonna see social unrest and so
there's not an all consensus in the
industry about that but I think there is
greater agreement about what this means
for inequality Patrick Callahan runs a
program for young people looking to get
the necessary skills for technology jobs
you know I think our responsibility and
I mean our responsibility as a society
is to retrain these folks for the jobs
that are going to be there not the jobs
that are always there today but the jobs
of the future yes anyone truly want to
be stuck in fast food their whole lives
some of us don't get that option to
change it I'm glad this program gave me
that option
actually work why I was fooled Tech
impact is funded by companies like
Microsoft and Accenture illustrating how
tech companies recognize the need for
retraining hi my name is Anthony casiano
I live here in Las Vegas Nevada
pretty much I'm lived here all my life
I mean I graduated high school and um
afterwards um I didn't really have a
plan would you have been able to save
the kind of money that you would need to
get through something like this um I
would say no ironically Anthony's night
job is as a janitor at a company that
makes automated gaming machines like
roulette and blackjack games
traditionally run by humans they always
have slot machines like wide open and
all the wires are in there other
motherboards everything it gives me kind
of an encouragement to see ok I could be
working and with this instead of working
with trash if I um keep doing well in
school so it's like something straight
there in my face it's a really good
motivator that question
the very motivation of work itself and
the foundations of why we humans labor
may be at risk as some question how much
labor there will actually be to go
around we can live in comfort and
security the trouble is we don't have
jobs and therefore we lose our identity
we lose what we are we lose our social
stature you have to have a social
structure in which you earn money in
return for something because that's the
way humans are motivated hey I'm Joel
with aj+ thanks for watching part 2
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and if you liked this episode don't
forget to check out the other two